uh kareem jackson previously with the
houston texans
past couple of years with the denver
broncos
appearing with akib talib on the
catching fades
podcast interesting things to say that
got desean watson's name trending
because there's the relationship there
between jackson and watson and they have
been talking
and here's what jackson had to say to
keep to leap
i got a great relationship with deshaun
i've been talking to him the last couple
weeks man
and like all he's been always been
telling me is like look
jack just tell him like that's where i
want to be
like he like that's where i want to be
like man listen that's why he like i
want to be in denver i want he's like in
in
like during the time i was going through
you know my little free agency thing and
then i ended up signing back here
before i signed he called he was like
man are you gonna sign him i was like i
don't know i ain't sure yet he's like
well
you know let me know what you gonna do
whatever whatever and i signed back he's
like listen man tell them that i i want
to be
in them
you know this desean jack desean watson
excuse me situation has been hanging
around since early january
more than five months later this is the
first time
first time it is prank me if i'm wrong
no i know your first time we have any
clear indication of what he wants
yeah by way of his next team yeah
there's been
suggestions there's been rumors you hear
miami
you haven't heard where he doesn't want
to go you haven't heard where he does
want to go
first time clarity he wants to go to
denver yeah
i mean it's uh it is it's kind of cool
to hear something like that publicly and
especially yeah
it holds more merit when it's kareem
jackson who played with him for
a long period of time you know now again
we don't know for sure uh i mean he
could also be talking to somebody on the
miami dolphin saying the same thing and
that guy just hasn't been interviewed on
the podcast yet you know
sure there may be five different teams
he's saying that's not where i want to
be
that's where i want to be that's where i
want to be right it's a very real
possibility at the very least we know
one thing he doesn't want to be where he
is right now he wants out of houston
badly and i i think we both agreed
denver was one of those teams i think we
heard a lot
early on in the process before all the
crap hit the fan for deshaun watson that
you know they were definitely involved
in the desean watson talk and the
sweepstakes and and wanting him and
everything like that
and again i know we've had these
conversations
but i think we feel the same way about
this
denver's one of those teams like you
just you know
you put a star next to you go watch out
wait offensive line got
fixed wide receiving court as dangerous
as anybody in any in football
you know of course vic fangio and the
defense was good and now they got
kyle fuller and patrick certain i mean
holy cow i mean they have a chance to
be a really special defense
and if they got the quarterback
situation figured out the right way and
i'm not saying drew locke or teddy
bridgewater can't figure it out but we
know watson can
they they could be a afc legit contender
with a guy like watson at quarterback
right away
broncos dolphins and eagles to me are
the three teams to watch the most
closely whenever it is that
the texans are able to trade watson and
get real value i continue to hear that
teams are trying
to generate something now even with the
baggage that goes along with the 22
lawsuits because you could buy him
low at a lower price get his contract
far less than what it's going to be
if those do get cleared away and all of
a sudden people are showing up
with multiple first-round picks plus and
that's i think one of the reasons why
the texans are resisting
because they believe they hope they
expect that at some point those cases
get resolved and they get a lot more for
deshaun watson and they look it's quiet
again it's quiet again
which when it's quiet as it relates to
those
lawsuits that tells me there's a chance
something could happen
and the cases could get resolved but
when you look at the broncos the
dolphins and the eagles
chris those are teams that could trade
for him now
or next year yeah it's not either or
no you could absorb him right now and it
would change everything for that team
for 2021
or you could see what you do with what
you have this year
and revisit it after the season it's i
don't
see except maybe tua in miami
i don't see any of the options with
those three teams
becoming so good this year
that you would say now we we don't need
desean watson in 2022.
yeah agreed agreed yeah i mean tua
because of where he was picked their
team you're right i mean even if he just
played solid football and they went 11-6
i don't know they probably have a hard
time
you know wanting to sell that or trade
him i i don't know now i mean of course
i would desean watson special
i mean he is he is one of the the five
or six best quarterbacks in football
there's no doubt about it
um you know i i think with like the
the denver situation i mean the weapons
at your disposal are unbelievable
miami pretty good eagles we know it's
it's kind of a work in progress
but like to me mike the question you're
asking that's the million dollar
question for these teams that are
really truly interested in watson is
like
i mean yeah do you want to do you want
to make it about this year like
to me this is where i would go with like
denver that's got to be a little
scary right now to if i'm vic fangio at
least
to want to trade for desean watson we
trade for him we give away maybe some
players on the roster right now future
draft picks
and we don't even know for sure yet even
though
we go on to get him for the low because
it's for the low but we don't know
he could end up suspended still
commissioner exempt list whatever it may
be
and now you've done that and yeah the
prospects are great for 2022 down the
road but you might not be there you
might be fired now
so that's where you know i think it's
tough in these situations and they got
to kind of
figure out do they want to be about now
in the future or whatever but there's
certainly some juggling there to think
about
well and that's where ownership has to
take over and say i don't care about
what this year or whatever yeah or
thinking this year next year whatever
deshawn watson
will play football again right you know
i
i'm i'm putting the finishing touches on
the manuscript for playmakers which
comes out next march
and there's a there's a chapter on
deshaun watson
which it's you know kind of difficult
to find a crystal ball that tells you
where
this is going to be in march but one of
the takeaways is
this guy's playing again unless he gets
indicted
convicted and incarcerated for 10 years
or longer which is ridiculously unlikely
at this point
unless that happens this guy's playing
football again
mike vick played football again and he
went to prison for two years
this guy's playing again and he's
already shown he can be one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl
he'll be back uh and and it would be a
stunner of all stunners if we never see
this guy again
and the question is who's going to end
up benefiting from having one of the
best players in football
on the field for another 10 years yeah
10 years longer right
guys mid-20s yeah even if he misses two
years like mike vick
he's mid-20s so uh he'll be back
by the way by the way update update on
the question of
the the quotes on the back cover
publisher
likes the idea loves the idea the back
cover quotes
will not be your standard fare it will
be a stream of insults so
anyone out there who's in the business
and and you know who you are i'm not
talking about
you know reporters i'm talking about any
coach wants to call me out any player
wants to call me out
do it please i beg you to and and
and the more profane and insulting the
better because it's going on the back
cover of that
well if you can't find them you know who
to call i'm sitting right here i'll give
you a good quote with some profanity and
some things that are bad about you no
problem i could put one on there for you
you just let me know friend all right
i love the idea i love it the fact that
you're gonna put
some negative quotes and things like
that out there it's very on brand for
you
you've always been able and willing to
take on those situations kind of head-on
and it's you know it's different you're
right it would catch my eye
reading a book and like wait a quote
from aaron rodgers don't read this crap
i mean that would literally
make me open up and go wait let me see
this crap in here i mean
what page is the crap oh crap if he's
commenting on this there must be some
good crap in here so yes
i i like it man it's it's gonna be cool
all right uh again uh who knows what's
gonna happen with deshaun watson but
whenever it's quiet that's when my
antennae
go up and so wait and just just to put
just to put this point on it chris yeah
the fact that they were haggling
over whether or not the settlement was
would be confidential tells me they had
an agreement in place for how much the
settlement would be
once you get there right once the people
involved especially the people who are
going to get the money
start thinking about getting the money a
lot of phone calls that come into the
lawyer are when am i getting my money
and and that momentum is hard to undo
yeah i
i you know i never thought of it that
way but that makes a lot of sense when
you put it that way yeah of course uh
the conversations had to be somewhat
down the road a little bit to get to
that point of whether we're going to
talk about confidentiality or not
all right here's the the last thing i'll
ask you at least for this subject or
whatever
like gut of guts do you think this
happens this year
or do you think it's something that
happens next year you know
my i want to say still i feel like yeah
teams are going to be interested and
call and continue to do that but i don't
know i guess in my heart of hearts i
feel like nothing will go down till next
next off season here's the problem for
the texans yeah
if they don't trade him by the time
training camp starts and we know how the
nfl is when it comes to the possibility
of paid leave they say
nothing no no and and i don't get the
impression that we even tell people
behind the scenes
antonio brown in 2019 now and maybe they
wanted it that way maybe they wanted
teams to not know what he was going to
be able to do
because that became a de facto unpaid
suspension yeah right with the texans
you're looking at the reality he's going
to show up he's going to show up because
he gets put on paid leave
texans got to pay him 10 million texans
got to ask themselves
at what point are we willing to take the
10 million dollar gamble what's it worth
to us
and this is a team that that wants up
what sent a second round pick to the
browns to take
16 million off the books so they
understand the connection between
cash value cap space and draft pick
compensation
at some point they've got to do their
flow chart they have to do their
their analysis from the standpoint of
we may have to pay this guy 10 million
dollars to not play for us this year
how does that affect our expectation of
what we would take in a trade for
someone else
to take on the possibility of paying the
guy 10 million to not pay i mean
play we we saw the ravens this week
they're paying juwan james 500 grand
right for rehab his achilles with the
possibility of him playing for them next
year
how much would you pay if you know the
guy wants to play for you and will play
for you in 2022
how much would you pay him to not play
for you
in 2021 yeah i could what would the
broncos pay 10 million i would to desean
watson
i mean knowing that they'll get him next
year right
i would think about it i mean yeah yeah
yeah it's it's okay you you've thrown
your team into flux for a little bit of
a year
certainly you hope he could fight and be
respectable but
i think like what you said a few minutes
ago is the point of the story
like yeah okay we lose a little this
year but we
gain a whole lot for the next 10 years
and that's where
you know the desean watson thing is is
different than you know
russell wilson or aaron rodgers like he
is just starting the prime of his career
last year was the best year of his
career
i know not wins or losses but you can
talk to anybody in football
who watch film and they are going to
tell you oh desean watson played his
best football last year without deandre
hopkins
and what he did he was efficient he was
smart he made plays
they had games yeah that they lost by
eight seven points
but i would sit there and go if they
don't have desean watson they would have
lost by 17 or 20.
there was a game because of desean
watson and what he can do
he's a difference maker he is the kind
of guy that can go get on my shoulders
we're a little flat today i can carry us
through until everybody gets going here
and that's there's only a few of them in
football that can really do that
and it's so easy to justify any team
that drafts a quarterback in round one
and is thinking about sitting the guy
for the whole year
how's this any different he's sitting
out a year right
we're paying him to not play right we
regardless
of when he'll be back or why he's out
we're paying him to not play and and by
the way
you give up a first round pick to get
him it's your 2022 first round pick
that's right
he's gonna play in 2022 all indications
are
so i i i would not be surprised the
question is
what will the texans take for him
yeah to get ready for the start of
training camp right just to be
done with it yeah all it takes is nick
casario
cal mcnair jack east to be whoever's in
charge down there rolling out of bed one
day and saying fine
fine this is the offer the broncos have
had on the table now we don't know what
is or
isn't out there and again i'm hearing
that the texans just won't even engage
at some point maybe they decide you get
away from mandatory mini-camp in the
off-season you got that four or five
weeks you get a chance to let things
settle down and think about what's to
come
when you start thinking about what's to
come and the possibility of paying the
guy 10 million dollars to not play for
the
this year knowing that you're not
getting him in 2022 makes it easier to
trade him to a team that'll pay him the
10 million potentially
this year and and realize
that they will get him in 2022 one last
point while i'm thinking of this yeah
you could you could set the compensation
based upon whether or not he does that's
exactly you're exactly right you're
right
right yeah they get more the texans get
more if it turns out
that the cases are settled and he plays
at least eight games yeah right
you get you get a second round instead
of the third round or whatever
exactly exactly yeah i'm i'm with you
you're right that's definitely out on
the table there with that situation to
smooth it over
no no doubt all right i got nothing else
to say about it you i just think
i think it's something we need to pay
attention to especially
as it's quiet quiet i hear the lawyers
aren't sniping
maybe things are moving in the direction
to get it resolved
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports